so what do you need to Bear the storm
what do you need and are there examples
of people doing it you need conviction
okay and yes there are examples of
people doing it I want to throw you to
something from February of 2022 this is
a little over a year ago this is Novak
Djokovic who basically is the best male
he is a male tennis player of all time
and you may remember that he did not
want to get uh the covid vaccine he has
an incredible not only physical regimen
uh but but nutrition regimen I mean he's
famous for this like a team of people
that are studying his body science and
everything else he was not even allowed
to compete in the Australia Open last
February because he was not vaccinated
anyway here he is in February 22 talking
about freedom of choice and bodily
autonomy
those were things that the lefties used
to talk about remember my body my choice
but here he is a year and a half ago and
you'll see why I'm showing this to you
in just a moment I understand the
consequences of my decision and one of
the consequences of my decision was not
going to Australia and I was prepared
not to go and I understand that not
being vaccinated today I you know I'm
unable to travel to most of the
tournaments at the moment and that's the
price you're willing to pay that that is
the price that I'm willing to pay
ultimately
are you prepared to forgo
the chance to be the greatest player
that ever picked up a racket
statistically
because you feel so strongly about this
Jab
yes
I do but as things stand if this means
that you miss the French Open
is that a price you'd be willing to pay
yes that is the price that I'm willing
to pay and if it means that you miss
Wimbledon this year again that's a price
you're willing to pay yes
because the principles of uh
decision making on my body are more
important than any title
or anything else
I'm I'm trying to be in tune with my
body
um as much as I possibly can it's a
really evil question the way that it was
framed because he is the best male
tennis player of all time I think now he
has 23 Grand Slam wins if I'm not
mistaken and you know the idea that
somehow that was it that wouldn't be
true the guy with the guy meant was okay
if you're not if you don't compete in
more of these because you didn't get
back you won't be the greatest of all
time but the point is he has conviction
right I don't need this thing and I am
willing to do what is right and it will
cost me money it will cost me treasure
it will cost me accolades Fame etc etc
now you may remember that even three
months ago three months ago this
headline from The Daily News uh Daily
Mail Novak Djokovic is denied entry to
the U.S again and will miss the Miami
open okay now you also might remember
that at one point uh Governor DeSantis
was trying to figure out a way to get
Djokovic in they were going to like
Charter boat that would somehow get him
to the Bahamas then into Florida anyway
that didn't happen
long story short you know what did
happen over the weekend so the guy did
not get the vaccine he missed a couple
opens he probably could have several
other Grand Slam wins uh in his belt
right now well he did win the French
Open this past weekend uh his 23rd Grand
Slam title here's a little video
foreign
guys that's a hero right there that's
actually a modern hero not only uh is he
the greatest male tennis player in
history but he stood up for what was
right